okay it's been a couple weeks since
we've had any hatred mail on the program
now there's been no shortage of me
receiving it we've just had so many
stories to cover I do want to get some
hatred mail in front of you today just a
quick reminder about what hatred mail is
why don't you take some
hydroxychloroquine for that trump
derangement syndrome patriot mail
written by Patriots who hate David
Pakman because America and because
freedom okay let's get right into it
this is us you know we've seen a lot of
disregard Ford disregard for the
Constitution and the First Amendment and
the rule of law lately from people who
claim to be constitutional conservatives
that's the context through which we
should consider today's hatred mail see
what you fail to realize David Parkman
is that your talk pisses off a lot of
patriotic Americans your talk is treason
and you should be tried and executed and
it's punks like you who will get the
coming Civil War started guess what
happens then you [ __ ] traitor you are
held accountable for your treasonous
words yeah so if there's going to be a
civil war it will be because the people
who would still be on the pro-slavery
Confederacy today are going to take up
guns and try to start a civil war the
Civil War is not going to be started by
people who want health care for
everybody right the Civil War is not
going to be started by those who believe
that we should have proper oversight and
reform of police departments that's
civil war is going to be from people who
still think that the Confederacy was the
right side of the actual Civil War and
it seems it's not just it's not just
Trump throwing around the word treason
as he did yesterday about Barack Obama
it's also hatreds that are doing it
remember that you can fight hate reott
ism by using the coupon code hey tree at
40 we have this code hey tree at 40 it
chops 40%
of the cost of a membership on my
website and the hatreds cry every time
it's used it's spelled h 8e r io t 4 0